what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna give you
a whole bunch of what diagrams I will
emphasize to you which one's your needs
should know as he if you see this word
you ought to recognize that it should be
able to give me the definition but that
will not be all of them some of them
would you be like do we have to memorize
that and the answer will be no I will
highlight the ones you really need to
know so first important one you start
with a triangle if you fall the lines
that are perpendicular to any side that
it's a sectarian excuse me that
intersect with the vertex that's
opposite that side you don't mind like
this like so hello you might know this
as the perpendicular height of the
triangle which it is if you were working
on an area but more specifically it is
called does anyone know starts with an A
it's an altitude very that's an altitude
now the curious thing about only
altitudes is that they're all if you
draw them and I'll do my best but I'm
gonna struggle
I tried all three altitudes are now does
anyone know another word start to exceed
that indicates concurrent they're all
concurrent at a single point that single
point there which you don't need to have
memorized the name of but I'm going to
tell you that because cool that's called
the author Center okay your visits are
so where the altitudes me you're gonna
know what announcer two years and a
quarter geometry proof or a deductive
geometry proof they might talk about
this altitude that altitude
they're not gonna explain that they're
gonna expect it you know that if they
refer to an auto center they'll probably
say the altitudes all be point P the
author center of the triangle etc so
that's not a word you're going to see
very often but is cooler after the
altitudes
that's not the only way to find the
inverted commas centaur of triangle
please another way if you take each side
and instead of forming a on a
perpendicular line to a side if it's
dead you break each side in half so for
example if I pick a point like that the
midpoint over here okay and if you join
that midpoint to its opposite vertex
like so okay you can do this for all the
sides measure out
okay now these three lines that we've
just drawn quite clearly not altitudes
they're a different thing right these
guys much less common they are called
medians and they're called medians
because just like in statistics the
median gives you the middle right it's
the middle score so the little excuses
romanians these lines they divide up
each side in half right they are in the
middle
hence medians the medians also are
concurrent which is astonishing really
of the name of where they all concur has
two names the one you'll see in math
textbooks tends to be centroid centroid
but another name you might hear up
especially if you go ahead and you do
physics where you are doing some physics
or if you're going to study more physics
is that it's called the barycenter
now that's a really fancy word that
means center of mass so if you cut out a
triangle out of a piece of paper right
and then you do this construction and
then you actually take a piece of paper
and you get that point and you put your
finger underneath that point the
triangle your paper triangle will
exactly rest on top of your finger
because that's exact center oh that's
assuming uniform gravitational fields
and so on okay so that's the century
also known as the better okay so another
contender for the center of the triangle
is what more center I'm going to show
you it's the least common but it's kind
of handy now can you see how here I've
got perpendicular lines here I have got
midpoint it's a natural kind of
direction to go in is to kind of take
the best of both worlds
what if you took all the midpoints right
so a big point
or something like this one but instead
of joining to the opposite vertices
which all of these are doing okay if
instead you opt for this go for the
midpoints but then you go perpendicular
okay all right okay so I've drawn a
bunch of rays okay so they start at
those midpoints there you go off at
right angles so they're all
perpendicular and then they just go on
forever okay what you have now created
is again something where all the lines
or rays are concurrent and this guy like
I said the it's the least common of all
of them centers but it's called the
circle okay now the reason it's called
the circumcenter is because spoilers a
little bit going forward okay this point
here is not just inverted commas a
centaur I have to say a centaur cuz
there are many different centers in the
Triangle it's not just the center of the
triangle it's also a center of a circle
that passes through all three points all
three vertices of the triangle it's just
gonna be really hard but I'm gonna try
anyway
well you know I did my best
okay there you go so we're going to get
into why when we transition into cats
the further I look at it that's it guys
we're going to go further into a circle
geometry and why it is that if you draw
any trail any triangle at all you will
define like the three points of the
triangle will define a unique circle
right for any given triangle there is
only one circle that can pass through
all three points you can't draw a
smaller line you can't draw a bigger one
you have to draw that exact one and this
is the circle that goes through all of
these points sorry really fancy what
you've done is you create a circle and
you have inscribed this triangle inside
that point is the center of this circle
now it's astonishing enough that the
altitude draw concurrent and the medians
are open current and the what would you
call these they are neither altitude -
nor minions they are rays but I could
make the dawn forever they are well I'm
going to go even further than that
they're perpendicular and do you see
they bisect every side of the triangle
right so perpendicular bisectors it's
astonishing enough that they are all
concurrent what's really really weird
is this fact and by the way this is not
in the syllabus or anything like that
but it's just so astonishing that I
can't not say it these three are better
covers centers of the triangle all three
centers are in fact if I put them all on
the one triangle they are all collinear
that line that they all pass through is
called the Euler line and when
something's named after Euler you know
it's like a big deal all right
they are all curling up always every
triangle and in fact it's not just these
three inverted commas and centers that
are on the Euler line there are other
centers that are printed one out but I
didn't have the heart to heart
I didn't have the heart to actually go
through the construction of it because
if that's my brain there you go okay
another way of finding the center of the
triangle and this Center which is called
the Exeter points named after a guy also
it lies on this boiler line it's pretty
crazy
go ahead go look at the Wikipedia
article for boiler line and it's been
called one of the most if not the most
profound results in all of geometry ever
and that's why it's got all this didn't
want it because that's what so you'll
need to know what an altitude is you'll
need to know what a median is once we
get to circle geometry so in like a
week's time you're gonna need to know
how to make the circumcenter as the
heart relaxed but that's the important
terminology that you'll encounter in